the yankees will try to make it six in a
row which would be their longest winning
streak of the year jamison tyone is on
the mound and david there are times that
tyrone looks lights out other times
there's a little bit of a slide back
what are you saying changing the style
on the fly is very difficult the
four-seam fastball has been good for him
but his secondary pitches need to come
along for the ride he's got a slider and
a curveball and i think he needs to use
his change up more to get past these
left-handed batters first and second one
out and here is jose abreu
line drive left field coming on and
duhar dives to make the play
safe
they say he trapped it so they get the
force now they go to second they're
tagging everybody out it's an inning
ending double play what haven't we seen
michael yeah so it looked like andrew
hart trapped it and the third base
umpire todd kitzler signaled it and now
he's talking to tyoon now he's talking
to tony larussa saying what went on
there now we'll see the ball was caught
i think he caught it he had his glove
yeah he had his glove under it reaching
across the wrong way but still
a good play so the the white sox are
going to challenge that as well they
should and the yankees gonna have to
come back out on the field so we have
anderson at second moncada at first and
here is mercedes swing and a miss tyonne
gets out of trouble no runs ahead no
errors and two men left on base he's on
for his tenth start his era at 444. not
going to strike out a lot of people not
going to walk a lot of people
surprisingly left-handers have really
hurt him this year he's gotten most of
the right-handers out that's because of
that sinker cutter combination with the
occasional chain the yanks have one on
one out and here is judge
the base hit for judge
boyd makes a big turn and eaton comes up
throwing to third
so first and second for the yankees with
one man out here in the first now geo
urchella
oh a tapper back toward the mound and
it's grandau
jumping out from behind the plate to get
out number two second and third shoe out
here is glaber
line center field base head
boyd scores here comes judge rounding
third here comes the throw home not in
time the third or second not in time
it is another two-run basis for global
taurus oh boy
it's labor day and global weekend two in
torres at second and sanchez the batter
struck him out two nothing yankees on
the torres hit well one away man here is
grandau swing and a miss mondale down on
strikes two way this is much more about
the
not the location but the uh you know he
had switched up the velocity the
fastball there slider before doll swings
right through it
billy hamilton lost one to left field
and duhar is there puts it away and a
one two three thing for jamison tyone
and the yankees dj le mayhew all for one
here's monkatta
oh short hop and a brave saves a run wow
jose with a pick to keep it two-nothing
here's nick madrigal
and there's glaber torres
and he gets madrid one away and here is
tim anderson
swing and a tip into the glove of
sanchez strikeout of anderson here's
judge one for one with a run
data as monkada at third has another
play and this one is a high throw for
round number two and two on with two out
gary sanchez struck out in the first 1-0
hit hard on the ground knocked down by
moncott he's going to have to throw to
first that throw is true here's abreu
runner on first
grounded to third there's one on to
first it's a double play
oh no mercedes just ducked into that
pitch
oh goodness
oh my your mean mercedes hit by that
breaking ball he was trying to get out
of the way but he ducked right into it
and you know he tries to duck under it
it hits the entire helmet that's the
best part of this i believe he's going
to stay in the game i think he wanted to
stay in the game dallas kykel will work
in miguel on duhar
got strike three called jim reynolds
punches out on duhar bring up gardner
who is struck out in his first at bat
swing and a miss for strike three might
have been a slider from kykel two
strikeouts in the inning we go to the
fifth here is billy hamilton a switch
hit of batting left
popped up
and geo rochelle makes the catch
so runner at first with chuman out and
here's tim anderson swinging and miss
five shutout innings for jamison taion
so judge walks and the yankees have the
bases loaded and no one out archella is
one for two
grounded and grabbed by moncada there's
one on the first it's a double play
lemayo scores voigt moves to third
yankees lead three nothing but marshall
got just what he needed here is glabor
who is as hot as the proverbial
firecracker
struck him out on the outside corner big
big strikeout for marshall now jamison
can say he took the baton and ran
35 straight scoreless innings last time
to happen 1932 yankees johnny allen
george pipgrass
ruffian red roughing and lefty gomez so
peralta comes on the line on taion five
innings no runs two hits four strikeouts
two walks so moncada is on and here is
abreu
like that oh is that right yeah into
left center field this is gone
96 out of here
and it's three to two that's why the
moncada at that was
important and that's why jose hitting
fastballs is even more important and
that's why his presence in the lineup
makes things a whole lot better for the
sox and he will deal to yerming mercedes
and the pitch is popped up
to shallow right
la mayu out lemayo makes a diving catch
on the line it was too far in for
frasier and the second baseman had the
angle and lemay who raced toward the
line made a dive and made a catch i mean
that's a terrific catch that's a double
that's a pop fly double down the right
field line and here is brett gardner and
the eggs have two on and one out
chop back to ruiz he fires the second
one on to first he throws it past the
british
here comes sanchez and he will score the
ball one into the yankee dugout and his
4-2 yankees
comeback trail can be paved by grand dog
here in the seventh to start it off
grandahl tags it to right field that's
well hit and it is
gone
bring him home just over the wall it's
four to three
yes took a couple of pitches and finally
hit it just far enough to get it
in the first row and you're only a two
pitch pitcher and one of them is not a
change up righty to lefty the lefty
usually has an advantage well here's
abreu hit a two run home run in this
game
grounded to third
there's one there it is again another
double play and here is oralis chapman
to close it out andrew vaughn's going to
bat for adam eaton vaughn is over his
last 16.
andrew vaughan charges this ball up into
right field we are
[Applause]
lights up chapman
we are level at four
the first ronnie's allowed
all year in the earned column well
andrew vaughn put a charge into that
gives you an idea just how powerful he
is because he took it opposite way
madrigal is over three the o2
did he go
yes he did didn't put it in play that
time and chapman escaped further trouble
4-4 game bottom of the ninth inning now
here's ty the wade with first and second
and one out of the pitch
slow roller going to be very tough to
get weighed that's going to be a basic
bases are loaded liam hendricks comes on
year old closure for the white sox three
and one there's no place to put judge
he walked in the yankees win
5-4 here comes frazier he'll touch home
plate how about that a walk-off walk and
the yankees sweep the white sox
this weekend in the bronx